hello and welcome to this video playing
lunatic ex again mr. McCulloch your last
game had a very nice position and lost
and with them you know in some slob a4
yes that's a line it's a sideline would
I keep forgetting I should definitely
look that up
and I think they could be for now i'm
not mistaken and before then d for
something
I don't know if c5 is collecting
not sure about it not sure why it's
still probably ghosty for
maybe
okay who I mean age and can take now be
true but that's not doing much probably
or is it it's not doing that much BP
three be three years just wrong I think
okay i think i need the night probably
over on the inside also there might be
Bishop g5
sorry for that sound and some of this is
kind of I don't know what they do they
work in the gun outside or something
yeah okay I'm trying to get rid of that
and bishop okay let's take it it will be
six here some pressure on d4 and cover a
six okay hmm I don't know Knight takes
and I takes it looks like negative actor
piece cable go back see four years
probably wrong okay I've are the
usefulness
26 or 2c 67 and probably rather to c 6
i'm not sure what the thing is doing on
g6 okay I ok that's interesting tries to
activate the bishop ok think I go back
maybe you can take now take a six
yeah maybe i can get counterplay and I
was thinking of taking Andrew p3 and
click gravity forces is covered quite
simply okay and I know it's better now
it's definitely better here in this
position
once that sounded glass and say oh my
god someone is cutting cutting the lawn
outside and the speed they're doing it
it probably takes hours okay so yeah
that bloody d6 porn so what to do now I
probably have to cover it
I can just take that hmm
and one day FC for something and
checking to get some counterplay 125
maybe I pawn takes though okay I'll go
here it's probably a OS is rookie to at
the end i guess i have to try something
active I didn't see it didn't see that
one and I was not difficult
time warning no I played that well I
think I probably has got these six or
something like that trying to cover that
at least can you see three is attacked
but probably not the end of the world
threatens checkmate but it's not not the
most subtle way of doing that ever yeah
yep I played that really okay I getting
I'm getting one porn back i get i guess
but be porn is still pretty substantial
26 probably
hmm e 6 i'm sorry not be six when you
can just take probably play whoop you
one Yankee Candle flip for Atkins I can
approach out the king hmm and now he's
got a six month yeah okay
it still is a loss yeah yeah resign name
that that looks like it looked that
looked ok for how I mean around here I
think I'm quite ok but he played it
probably quite well unless I take one c3
and we know what I can do this this and
I'm a corner may I didn't think of this
because usually you don't open up here
on the queenside you just try to keep
this position closed yeah I mean it's
not the end of the world you can take
here and play this position but is still
upon down ok I didn't see that one yeah
and the wrong key i'm probably getting
into trouble that looks very very normal
this yeah this is just better fam it's
just better for him that bishop is
stronger and i cannot get him I cannot
trade it out anything when I go 9 a-5 he
goes Bishop t5 and so on no it's better
for wide I mean I don't need to lose
quickly so quickly as i did but white is
better and this is all gold strong yeah
try to try to fish a little bit
david.quinney 3 is an easy easy reply to
that now there was a well played game by
white for sure i didn't really have
anything there ok i could have taken
twice on d4 but that didn't cross my
mind at all ok well thanks for watching